la fête de l'internet avec cet exemple
tout à fait inédit celui d'un petit
village de quelques centaines
d'habitants
tous se raccorder web il s'agit du
village de show reportage dorothée
cochard et sylvain de bain chaud village
de 800 âmes une qualité de vie comme on
dit le charme bucolique des bords de la
meuse et cette impression d'être un peu
loin du monde c'est faux chaussée le
village le plus branché de france je
cherche des voyages et l'envoi des
messages
ici un habitant sur deux utilise
internet
mais pour l'instant je n'ai pas
tellement le temps de me servir
d'internet mais c'est surtout mes petits
enfants pour des exposés dizaines
c'est intéressant pour ce petit j'allais
cela pour la petite jeunesse et pas
seulement achopper les maisons ont une
connexion gratuite offerte par la mairie
à chacun de profiter comme il l'entend
je ne me laisse pas griser par ni
l'ordinateur ni je fais pas je travaille
pas sur internet hors internet c'est
quand j'en ai besoin
c'est comme ma voiture internet gratuit
un petit paradis qui a son secret la
centrale nucléaire
grâce à elle ce sont trois millions et
demi de francs de taxe professionnelle
qui sont versés à la commune
la grande question était que faire du
pactole
faire venir des autoroutes de
l'information à la place des cordes
classiques ne sont pas les faire venir
ici acheter ça moyen pour nous de nous
désenclaver le petit commerce n'est pas
encore en ligne
loin s'en faut mais chacun à quoi tirer
profit du nouvel outil un exemple ça
trois sets de couler le poivron nouvelle
les trouver sur internet
mais n'allez pas croire que le tout est
joué la roussette ne fait pas tout a
bonne entendeur salut les internautes
ont leur moral science sans conscience
n'est que ruine du palais